Hey, what's going on and spill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Ah,
just checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on just
seeing how your week's going. Okay.
You know a lot of people when
they podcasts for one week,
they don't fucking think about their
listeners for the rest of the week,
but you know what, not this
guy, I think about you.
I think I think about you.
Or what was it that was
fucking a guns and roses,
right? All that fucking false
settles singing back then. Oh, Lee,
you,
Ooh,
Ooh.
Everyone will go nuts and they would have,
their fucking light is up in
the air already. Right out
of the gate. You can say,
Gee, Bill, you have a lot more
energy than you've had lately.
What's going on with you while ty,
what's going on?
Today's the last day we're
wrapping on the movie front runner,
storing a Hugh Jackman
directed by Jason Reitman.
Um,
this is the last day.
I'm very excited because I think
it's going to be a great movie.
And I also get to go home and see
my family is that my daughter away.
Um,
very cool.
I've got a quick little run in New York
and then I'm done and I'm just done for
the rest of the year. Other than the Times
I go to New Mexico and Arizona. Okay.
I mean, I still am a traveling
comedian. I still am a plate spinner,
but uh, I'm pretty much home til like
the end of January, which is awesome.
So I will be spending that time
with my family and uh, going in,
punching up an editing,
some of the first cuts of a season,
three of f is for family. That's what I'm
doing, you know, getting into the, uh,
thanksgiving spirit,
thanksgiving often overlooked.
You know, the second Halloween comes
along, everybody goes, oh shit,
it's the fucking Christmas season.
But people forget that there's a holiday.
You know,
the holiday, you don't have to have
any gifts. All you gotta do is show up.
You show up the Wednesday
before thanksgiving,
you go down to the local bar and a lot
of the checks that you were too afraid to
talk to are going to be down there.
A lot of the chicks that were afraid to
be talked to are going to be down there.
Everybody's looking for
some sentimental sex.
Right.
Awesome.
What if encounters counters?
Yeah.
Sorry. I don't mean to go.
I'll Harvey Weinstein here.
All of that was consensual.
All right. Jesus Christ. It's
just one accusation after another.
Finally, please. All these famous
people are starting to go like, yeah,
I have no idea who that is or, yeah, I
don't, I dunno. I don't remember that.
Yeah.
You know, which I was surprised right
out of the gate. They didn't do,
I'm not condoning their behavior.
I'm just saying legal advice. Yes.
Later after the ges has disappeared off
for you throughout the plant that you
fucking came on,
you'd think that these people would go
into denial like that fucking Supreme
Court judge. God, I don't know what
you're talking about. I didn't do that.
I just went back to my study and I was
reading on how to become a better person
this slowly starting to
do that. Um, but anyways,
why,
why bill?
Why on such a glorious holiday month
would you bring up such a scandal?
Um, there should be like, you know what,
you should start doing like a, like,
you know, you have like a dead pool. They
should do. You should do like a pool now.
We just fucking,
you try to bet on who's the next person.
Okay.
I can't even say anything because it's
not funny to fucking accuse somebody.
That shit.
Uh,
okay.
I'm trying to think of anybody who I with.
Nah, I ain't going to fucking do that.
Let's, let's get it. Let's
go with something positive.
I went to the best music store.
I've been to an eye since,
I dunno when with the best
commercial on Youtube,
which I am going to post off of the Monday
morning podcast, Twitter account, uh,
Portman's music store in Savannah,
Georgia is a hands down the best
music store I've been to. Um,
what do you want? You want
a French horn? The got it.
You want to assume they got it. You
want to Didgeridoo, they got it.
Are you an old man and you've got to read
some charts and your fucking eyes are
gone. They actually sell readers up
at the, up at the counter a little,
you know those glasses when you don't
want to just waste your money getting a
prescription, do you just go
out and you get the readers?
You just try some on and I think
these are good. These are go right.
They sold those.
Uh,
I went over there and just to get some
drum sticks and next thing you know,
I'm actually thinking of buying a trumpet.
Okay.
I always loved the trumpet. I always loved
the power of that fucking instrument,
you know?
And uh,
I actually looked at one for the first
time I had this guy explained to me the
whole way that it worked
and I was thinking about it.
And then fortunately I
called my wife and she goes,
you're not buying a fucking trumpet.
Why do wives always do
that? They always, you know,
I'm not saying that she was wrong,
but they always do you that doing that.
You're not buying a boat.
Okay?
You can do get that. Putting a speed
bag up on the side of the house.
Well, you know it doesn't rain that
much. There's a tree over it, honey.
We're not doing that right.
They always do that to us,
but what can we always ever sit there
and look at and be like, like why honey?
You're not buying another pair of shoes.
You're not buying any more throw pillows.
Okay?
You already can't sit on the
fucking couch. There's too many.
I'm not yelling now.
I am.
Yes, but I wasn't. Oh,
you know what? Fuck you.
Fuck you fine. I don't give a fuck. I
never didn't want to go there anyways.
What do you hope to ruin the weekend?
Right?
That's the way it goes.
Why can't we do that? What?
You know, we should just,
we got to figure out what they do.
Obviously we can't start crying, you know?
No fucking send us to some God damn home.
I'm going to do that next time. Buying
a trumpet. You're not buying a trumpet.
Dopey.
Hey me.
She was right in another
life, you know. Come on man.
The trumpet with the plunger on the end,
getting that Jimi Hendrix. Why Wah sound.
Maybe that's where, that's probably
where he got it from. Right.
He probably wanted to have that sound
in the guitar because he was probably
listening to somebody playing a fucking
horn. I don't know what, but uh,
I always loved the trumpet
and the trombone and the
sac saxophones kind of hacky
to like, that's like Lichen Guitar.
Everybody likes fucking guitar.
Everybody likes somebody comes to horns.
Everybody likes to saxophone. Right?
Fucking Trump owns the
shit. Right? The trumpet.
Yeah. But listen to a big band and
those four trumpet players show up.
They fucking, you know, they stand up and
they start playing their little section.
They almost knock you out of your seat.
MMM.
I Dunno man. They were fucking cool.
And they were expensive as shit.
Like the cheapest one was like that
they had, there was like six, seven,
800 bucks when the parents are always
fucking freaking out when that kid stops
playing. The trumpet.
It's like, Dude, you know?
Yeah.
I could have bought a new ride mower.
Okay.
Do you know what stopped me from playing
the trumpet? Other than, uh, just poor,
you know, musical gifts was, I didn't
want to get that fucked up live.
And then the guy behind the
counter told me, he said,
all that's just poor technique.
That's just from pressing, I probably,
you're ambitious. Sure. Or whatever
the fuck they call it is wrong.
So to make up for it,
you got to press it against your lips and
then you get like that, that, you know,
yeah.
You look like look like somebody beat
you with a trumpet rather than you play
one.
Right.
Okay.
And he's like,
now you just want to be relaxed.
You want to be relaxed since everything
is that in life, you know what I mean?
Do you want to be relaxed? You want to
hit a home run? Don't try and kill it.
Just swing through the fucking zone. But
the bat, meet the ball. There it goes.
Right Ben? A little league
field for me. Professional guys,
they could hit it out of Fenway plaque,
right? Stop trying to kill it. Golf,
you want to drive it a bunch of yards
there, right? You want to show off?
Okay.
You're on the first tee.
Have you all the fucking white
dude standing behind you?
One woman,
it's somebody of color so nobody can
say you're fucking membership is racist,
right?
You fly them in.
Okay.
Everybody's standing there watching
you. You're waiting to tee off, right?
You feel in the sweat going down the
Becky a ball bag. And what do you do?
You grip it a little tighter.
You fucking go back like John Daly,
you swing outside your zone
and you fucking go through
your little hat with the
palm. Palm falls off, you fall
on your ass, you white slacks,
get a grass date on them. And
where does the ball go? Huh?
Fucking ricochets off the lady's
tastes and everybody snickers,
everybody snickers and
you're in a bad mood.
You have a bad round and then you fucking
come home. You throw your clubs down,
right?
And then your wife comes out.
And once you to emote
and next thing you know,
you get your hands around her throat,
right? Her eyes are rolling back.
She's making dents on the what
you then you know how it ends,
right?
You know how it ends.
It ends with a trip to home depot.
You're buying a pick ax and some
sort of lime and all you had to do,
all you had to do was just relax.
Go up this smile and wave at all
your so called friends that you know,
a route and against you. You
know, stay within yourself.
Be Nice and relaxed.
Don't give a shit.
Let the face meet the fucking ball there
it goes right down the goddamn fairway.
But no,
you tried to kill it and one and ended
up happen. An innocent woman died.
Right. And how you're
going to get caught. Huh?
Because of the back of her head that the
imprints going to be on the hood of the
car. They come over
there to dust it, right.
And then they'll still be able to tell
it's the perfect shape of her skull with
the little blue, a little pony tail.
You know, and then you just sit there.
That's when you break down on
the, on the fucking Stan like, oh,
I'm one of those classic uh,
iron side,
the writer with Manny.
You remember those old
stupid court dramas,
the early days of movies
and television shit.
All the had to do was just ask the person,
the defendant a bunch of quick questions.
They'd just be like, you went golfing
that day, didn't ya? Yeah. What about it?
Everyone was watching it one day.
They were watching and you're squeezed
the glove chloride. No, I didn't get,
and then you went home and your
cows. Why? Right. I did it.
Yeah.
[inaudible] my golf game, Shea. Right.
They always did that. And then they
always shook women and slap the,
okay.
You know, when that was the backbone. Oh,
Hollywood. And for some fucking reason,
67 years later, everybody's surprised
that people are running around,
grabbing people by their private,
Eh, finishing on a plant.
Um, anyways, I guess, was it the midterm
elections? I don't. What happened?
All I know is I was down on the
sets and somebody said, hey,
it's a good good day for Democrats.
And I was just like,
uh, what do you mean? He goes
yesterday, man, he said the Democrats,
Democrats fucking killed it yesterday.
And my first thought was, well,
did they elect good Democrats?
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
I know like how people look at politics,
the way they look at their sports team,
you know what I mean?
Where like if it's a bad call, as long
as it goes into the favor of your team,
you're like, God, that was fine.
You know like Hillary supporters
doing that stupid. Thank you Hillary,
which was probably started by her people.
MMM,
okay.
I don't understand what
people on the left are doing.
Still trying to push her over the top.
At some point you just got to admit you
wasted a draft pick and you got to move
on to somebody else.
Okay.
I've never seen somebody just keep
coming back like fucking Freddy Krueger.
I since probably Richard Nixon,
that has to be her spirit
animal. My favorite. My fucking,
what did I just say?
Favorite.
That's the thing I hate the most when
people say so and so is my spirit animal.
When you fucking 11, you've
got a pen pal too. Um,
yeah, like if I was her, I would just, I
would look, I would look at Richard Nixon
and be like, okay, this guy lost you.
No one on the radio last on TV.
He was sitting there, you know,
sitting there like how you normally sit,
right? He's got sweat on his upper lip.
JFK comes in all tanned up.
He's got his legs crossed,
like he's doing panel on the
fucking tonight show. You know,
all the women are watching going off.
I had to fuck a political dick.
That would be the Dick. Right? So
everybody fucking votes, you know,
thinks that he went on TV,
Nixon loses the election,
and then he lost the governor's race
and California and literally was out of
politics
in that eight years later,
oh, tricky dick came back and
won the fucking White House.
I think that's what
Hillary is trying to do.
MMM.
But just watching everybody on the left,
just ignoring,
completely turning a fucking blind eye
to the fact that Bernie Sanders got more
votes and the Di they
admitted it in court.
The Democratic National Party colluded
with her campaign to make her the fucking
representative. I mean, can
you give me a fucking break?
She's fucking sitting here bitching about
the electoral college. I don't get it.
I get, if you're a woman and you want
a woman to be president, but you know,
can you pick a good one?
Can we start with that?
MMM.
I mean, how much more corrupt
can, I dunno, I just don't get it.
Peoples and being a namerd with
either the bushes or the Clintons,
I, I've had enough with them. I
want a new last name lying to me.
Is that asking too
much? Um, but so anyway,
so I checked out some of those elections
and I'm way in over my head here,
but I just saw these weird headlines like,
congratulations,
such and such state,
you elected the first transgendered
person way to go Vermont or way to go New
Jersey. You elected the first, uh,
Muslim, whatever, that this seat guy,
whatever,
I don't know how to say to whatever,
there was nothing in there that you
elected somebody who was qualified that's
going to do a great fucking job.
Who happens to be Polynesian or whatever.
I don't understand it. Read the
exact same. Well that's like,
that's like how white supremacy vote.
You know,
they vote strictly by you know,
race or whatever.
Like that doesn't make any sense. Like
can we just vote for people who are good,
who actually have demonstrated that they
can not be swayed by money and they're
actually going to do what's going to be
good for the environment that's going to
be good for poor people,
middle class people that's going
to be good for this country.
Don't just fucking vote for somebody
because of their genitalia or,
or you know, I mean I
don't get, I don't get it.
This whole fucking idea that
that sociopath's selfish people.
Liars are only white male heterosexuals
and that only they are susceptible to.
Um, being weak when they
get positions of power is,
is, is not a good road to go down is the
only thing I'm going to say. You got to,
I don't know how you, uh, figure out
what the fuck somebody going to do,
but like to just be excited that somebody
got in there because of their sex or
their race is a,
is a very shortsighted way to look at it.
You got to look at what the
fuck they did is all I'm saying.
And I did not see that in the
headline. I just thought, oh good,
this person's in there,
you know?
But I feel like that's how we
try to fix shit. Like, oh my God,
there was eight years of Democrats.
Fuck this. Let's do, let's,
let's vote all Republican. Uh,
wait a minute, that doesn't work.
Let's go all Democrat.
That's what we just keep fucking doing.
And now we're going to do
that. I think on a, a, uh, a,
uh,
what do you call it?
Gender and a race thing is what they're
going to do and it's going to be
fucking, I'm telling you, you're
going to see the exact same scandals.
I did not have sex with that woman.
You wait, I wanted to see how this
plays out when they get in there, right?
When the [inaudible] get in there and
they got their own private fuck and
subway, you know everybody's
eating fucking lobster,
you know, and it's all just
sitting there dangling. You know,
you want to be present. Hey Buddy,
you want to be president, right?
And they got to get in bed with all
of these evil fucking corporations.
And then when they get in there, they
got to do with those corporations one,
okay.
Right. They got to do what the fuck
they want. And then if they do,
then you end up like, like
Obama, like Bush, like Clinton,
like all of these fucking
people after their president.
Then you go on the fucking
bribe money tour going out,
air quote giving speeches, right?
Why are you still giving speeches?
You're not president anymore.
You know what I mean?
Is Dan Marino walking around with
a football still throwing passes.
He's retired. What the fuck
are you all your collect? Yeah.
Obama right now is on tour.
$69 million toward giving speeches.
Let's say the guy doesn't
give a good speech,
but 69 million in one year.
The Fuck Outta here.
The Fuck Outta here. Who's he going to
go talk to? Huh? What was he talking to?
Joe Six pack? I don't think so. Um,
I know that was a very
bleak way of looking at it,
but there's something positive in there.
I think we need is as
everybody represented,
obviously in government,
but you got to make sure
that you're not just voting
okay.
You know, just to get a
woman in. There are some,
you gotta make sure they're good
and that is, that is my problem.
Okay.
With the Clintons,
I just think that they're just fucking,
they like, I don't even know what they
are. They just soulless fucking people.
There's gotta be somebody better than
her. All right. But you know, Democrats,
if you want to hang your hat around,
somebody with Mike Dukakis
is fucking charisma. Who's
his comfortable in his own,
her own skin is Al Gore to fucking loses.
They can't say well to
people lost the election. Um,
have you ever heard me talk
politics as much in your life?
Would you think someone who doesn't watch
Fox News or CNN or MSNBC or anything
else who kind of just gets his news from
overhearing one comment from somebody
on a set? Well, doing
eight lines in a movie.
Um, anyway, so let's get back into my
wheel house. All right. What happened?
This is the podcast.
I fucking talk about what I want.
I talked about buying a trumpet, Ed
and I'm talking about, uh, you know,
make funny for woman gets in the office.
Like, like, what is she gonna like,
how is she going to give it to,
you know,
okay.
She going to get like a
bunch of fucking like j crew
like boy toys running around
the White House. Who knows?
I don't know what they're going to do.
She'd probably go like that.
That Ferdinand Marcos chick there who
had like fucking 50,000 fucking shoes.
That's what it is. Guys are into
like fucking, we're animals, right?
Ladies are into stuff.
Maybe that's what it is.
They'll blow the entire defense budget
and I'm like broaches or some shit.
All right. This is some of the
dumbest Shit I've ever said. Um,
I hope it makes you feel better
about yourself. All right. Oh,
last day of the shoot, 84 days
sober. I did it. All right.
I booked this thing. I was a fat
booze bag. I stopped fucking drinking.
I did it.
So can you and I'm so I'm a little
nervous here because now the shoot ends
tonight and uh,
so now what do I do?
It's this weird thing where I don't
want to, I don't want to end my streak.
I forgot.
I can get at least a hundred days then
I'm going through Thanksgiving without
drinking.
But is that a bad thing?
You know what I mean?
Rather than, you know,
drinking and kind of forgetting half the
meal and then waking up at four in the
morning, what the TV still on, you know,
sweating my ass off and some Thanksgiving
sweater being like, what the fuck?
Where is everybody? Did I
say goodnight? You know,
next day you go downstairs, you talked
to your wife, feel like a good morning.
She just looks at you and keeps brushing
your teeth and you're like, oh fuck.
Um,
did you have fun yesterday?
She stops brushing your teeth,
slams a hand down on the counter,
spits out, and that fucking
turns the sink on. It.
Turns it off and then turn
and you're like, oh fuck.
What did I do? What did I say?
I don't want to do that.
I'll do that the day after,
right when I watch all those
rivalry game followed in Alabama,
crimson tide against the Auburn
Tigers, um, I'm missing everything.
I don't know what's going on in the world.
Uh,
I had a lot of people send me a,
you know,
tweets and texts and all that shit.
Unfortunately about the fatal crash.
Uh,
sorry, I just clicked this
fucking thing off. Um, uh,
Roy Halladay and uh, yeah,
that's fucking brutal.
That's brutal.
Did she,
that guy in Boston sports radio
just fucking went off on him.
MMM.
You know,
what's hilarious about that whole clip
is he makes his point in the first like
eight seconds. He says what he feels
about it and then continues to say it.
I almost thought it was like on a loop.
He just kept going, oh, look at me.
I got to play the idea.
I'm waving at the fucking window.
He said that like nine times.
Um,
I was kind of done with the guy
when he called Holiday a Jack Wagon
who says,
I
understand you can't curse on the radio.
Um,
yeah,
I dunno. But the weird thing is
that there's, they're blaming the,
they're starting to
blame the plane and uh,
I don't think that's right. I mean,
if it's pilot error both times,
I don't think that that, you know,
what's scary is the other one. Right.
And I've even thought about this the
first time, that type of plane crashed,
I guess the test pilot,
he went flying into this
canyon flying low and he,
they're guessing that he thought he was
in this different part of the canyon
that was going to,
it opened up to a lake.
But this one didn't like it started
to get narrow and then he went into
basically a mountain
called the sac and he,
and basically the angle that he would
have had to fly out if he pulled back on
the stick,
he was going to fucking stall.
So he had to try to do
bang a Uie basically
I would think. Um, yeah,
that's why I like a
helicopter cause you just go,
just stop with those fucking things.
You have to keep like a shark.
They got to keep moving forward
other than that's fucking it. Um,
okay.
But I gotta tell you, man, that plane
looks cool as hell. It really does.
It really looks cool. And um, I dunno,
but all of this shit where
people speculate and all
that, just shut the fuck up.
All right. The FAA will
investigate and like whatever.
And then in a certain amount of
time, six months, a year, whatever,
they'll come out with
their official report.
All these fucking people who don't fly,
listen to them talk about,
it was kind of a, I dunno, it was
kind of funny. Like they said, no,
this is the third time,
blah blah blah. You know,
there's a lot of times if something's
easy, people will do dumb shit with it.
Like the helicopter that I
want to buy, you know, it's,
it's basically like the Robinson,
but they corrected all the safety
issues on it. First of all,
having a fully articulated main rotor
system where you could actually push the
stick forward and not enter into some
sort of low GI or mass bumping situation.
So there was a guy that got it and he
was trying to demonstrate how you could
fly like an asshole,
which is what you should never do.
And he slammed the stick forward and
he went into a nose down attitude.
But it was, it's a carborated
engine and the way the fuel is,
is fed in.
When he tipped it forward,
he basically starved the carburetor
of fuel and he stalled it,
demonstrating that he wouldn't
get into one situation.
He created another situation
and then he then crashed it.
So, you know, people
will always, I, you know,
the very little that I know about
aviation, whenever a new design comes out,
you know, people are always
like, well, let's see,
let's let people fly in it and let them
die and then they can fix it and let you
warn you about all of this stuff.
But a lot of times it's just people,
it's this weird thing
where they make it safer.
Okay.
It make it easier and then
yeah,
someone will then do something.
I don't know,
I'll do something like that,
just slam a stick forward or something.
So I have no idea what that guy
was doing, but it's brutal, man.
So obviously condolences out to
him and his wife and kids. Man.
It's fucking brutal. Um, all right,
when, what? That's sad frigging story.
MMM.
That guy in Boston radio though.
It was also like,
I feel like as much as he felt what he
was saying, he was also trying to be edgy.
MMM.
You know,
and it's one of these things,
if anything that he was
saying was actually true,
it's like two kids don't need to say that.
Why are you adding to the pain of his
family if you really give a fuck about his
wife and kids? All right. If
somebody did something dumb,
everybody knows that they
did something dumb and,
and then they died then shut
up. Just shut up about it. Me,
you should really upsets me.
It upsets you.
Upset you don't even know the fucking guy.
It was such like a car. Dashi and two,
I just felt like for me that
was really upsetting. Um,
anyways, me undies, everybody, uh,
Mian Andy's beyond these. Don't slam
the fucking stick forward to Mondays.
Mondays, if you were in the Cabrini
fucking whatever I want to buy. Um,
why would I go into that?
Why? Why the fuck would I
die? What can I say beyond me?
Biondi swing the club.
Nice. No single golf club.
Relaxed Doo Doo Doo Doo.
Brds yeah.
Yeah.
You got nothing to run it through the
legs. Cause I'm thinking that fucking,
I'm sorry. You know what? I feel like
Casey case am I just went from a tragic,
tragic fucking story to singing
about underwear right now.
You can't make that transition.
Mandy's, everybody, me,
undies makes your butt me undies.
Your button will be proud
to wear and check this out.
I'm not the only one who loves me undies.
Listen to what longtime listener and
me undies enthusiast George has to say.
I note from George n a bill
burr listener and be undies fan.
I decided to try it. Mandy's BC. He
goes, I love bear, bear, bear. I sat it.
Okay. Is that all right? I did it.
I tried it on their soft melody
underwear. My Dick liked it. Okay. Um,
I smile every time he sings the song.
Although it's so easy to
skip the ads and the podcast,
I always listened to bill re Baba
Baba Baba. You guys know this.
He loves these fucking things.
They're nice and comfortable and he loves
me on these cradling the family jewels
to get 20% off the best and softest
underwear and socks you will ever own.
Free Shipping and a hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash bird
that's me, Andy's dot com slash bar. Well,
that was too short. I should read
what the guy said. All right.
I always listen to bill's reed and I'm
so glad we, Yannis has stuck with them.
It's been probably two years since I
bought my first pair of me and he's,
and now I have a monthly subscription
because they are that comfortable before
me undies.
I used to buy the three pack of underwear
and retail stores until I realized
that I wanted to treat my junk
to something more comfortable.
And that starts with a great pair of
Mandy's cradling the family jewels that is
just so slick.
The way that is read it reeks of and
that it was rewritten by the advertisers.
I'm sure there's a George n out there,
but I don't think he wrote
it as eloquently as that.
If he did go to Madison Avenue a kid,
you've got a career, you got a field cha.
All right, legal zoom,
everybody. As a business owner,
you know how important it
is to keep moving forward.
But a lot of times things come up that
take your time and focus away from
growing your business.
So when it comes to reviewing contracts,
registering for trademarks are staying
current on fees and permits. Legal,
zoom.com can help simplify your life.
Uh,
and they help me more than 2 million
business owners easily and affordably
navigate the legal system with confidence.
The best part,
you never have to worry
about an attorney's billable
hours piling up because
legal zoom is not a law firm.
Instead you get the advice you need to
answer your business questions at fixed
rates through legal zooms, nationwide
network of independent attorneys.
So take some pressure off yourself.
Go to legalzoom.com now to take care of
your business before the year winds down.
And for special savings,
be sure to enter code burr in the
referral box at checkout. That's burpee.
You are are for special
savings only@legalfilm.com.
All right, let's continue on here.
Um, I had been so frigging, uh,
busy traveling around doing shows and
finishing up this acting gig that I have
not watched. One second of my beloved
Boston Bruins and Boston Celtics.
I haven't watched anything. And, uh,
a friend of mine on F is for family.
A Cleveland Cavaliers Fan was raving
about how well Kyrie Irving was doing with
the Celtics.
So I watched a little bit of highlights
last night of the Celtics defeating the
Lakers. I saw that Lonzo Ball, is that
his name or is that his dad's name?
I saw that he actually played well and
believe in, not even as a Celtics fan.
I'm happy for that dude because his
fucking dead is like such a crazy person
that it makes people hate this kid.
The kids never said Shit,
you can't pick your parents. And that
Dude's dad did a lot of good things.
He is playing in the NBA,
but um,
I don't know what he's doing.
He's fucking wrestling.
MMM.
I don't know what the fuck he's doing,
but that's going to be
one of those things.
At some point that kid is going to have
to make it very uncomfortable break with
his overbearing father. Uh, but anyways,
the Celtics won and I'm watching the
highlights and I don't know anybody on the
team anymore. We still got, MOC is smart.
It seems like we got rid of everybody
else. Crowder, Avery, Bradley,
Isaiah Thomas. I knew they were all gone,
but it, you know, Kelly, a Lennox gone.
Everybody's fucking God. This is like
two people left from last year's team.
That kid green was looking great. What
the hell did he go? I was all, I didn't,
I missed all of these
fucking trades. So, um,
I dunno, I'm right back to only being
able to name a couple of Celtic. So, uh,
I'm excited that, uh, this, I'm
going to get back into them.
I'm going to get through my, uh,
my little New York around here.
Thank you by the way, to everybody
that's coming out to my show Sunday night
and uh,
in New York City.
Thank you for getting bit in the tickets.
You're going to watch
me trout some material,
fuck around and do some shit that works
and do some shit that doesn't quite work.
And, um, but when I come
back, when I come back,
I am a [inaudible].
It's it. I'm watching the NBA
and NHL package and I can't,
I'm so fucking psyched up going out and
buying my nieces and nephews a bunch of
gifts. Uh, I'm going to come
back east for Christmas.
Everybody in my family who hasn't met my
beautiful, gorgeous, lovely daughter, uh,
my wife sent me video yesterday of the
first time she was on a swing, which are,
you know, thank God for video.
I would have missed it. Yeah.
MMM.
Uh, it's just awesome. She was so happy.
And then the way she was sitting there,
she had like an elbow, like she was
hanging out the driver's side window.
She was so totally chill.
She has like a, like a,
like a relaxed confidence about her
and she's a sweetheart, you know?
So all I gotta do is not be
an angry maniac. You know,
who can do, I'm going to be an angry
maniac, but I'm going to be less of one.
And when she calls me out on it,
when she inevitably learns how to talk,
I'm just going to admit to it, be
like, you know what? You're right.
Daddy needs to work on that because a,
I don't wanna I don't want
to ruin what she looks like.
She's gonna be mad cause she, I just
kids going to be special. You know,
like all dads, I am a little
biased, but I'm telling you, um,
anyways, which is another reason to not
be boozing around the frigging house.
Right.
Uh,
I think that's what I'm going to do.
I think in, in, in the next year,
I'll keep my drinking on the road.
That's what I'll do.
I live this double life
stone sober at home,
pushing her on a swing, wearing
sweaters, smiling and waving.
And then on the road I'll just
be in the gutter after my shows.
It's too sad. I would
never do that. Um, anyways.
And I heard that kid for the Bruins,
that kid on bu who stepped up last year
was [inaudible] looking very promising.
I heard he's playing really well.
I heard the Bruins of fast.
I know we don't have the greatest
record at this point, but you know,
a long season,
I cannot fucking wait to get
back to my family and just a,
you know,
I don't know.
I'm not going to do shit for like
two weeks right through thanksgiving,
right until the end of this
month. And then I'll, you know,
whenever you'll start getting busy again.
But who gives a fuck? I'm a really,
and try to enjoy the holidays this
year. I'm getting into it. All right,
I'm going to buy a fucking tree.
I'm going to do the whole thing.
Although where I usually buy my tree,
you know,
got all everything got all fucked up
down there, announced. So they prep you.
They can't sell the trees there.
Who knows what?
They'll probably knock it down the
building to put up another building.
That's the big move out
here, right? Build these, uh,
I don't know what you call them.
These high rises, luxury
rentals. Do yourself a favor.
Don't rent a luxury apartment when
you can just instead go out and buy
a starter house. Throw all that
money down the fucking toilet. Okay?
Please don't do that unless you want
it. If you want to do it, by all means,
go ahead and do it. So, um, I was
reading, I always read drum magazine,
I Read Modern Drummer magazine and,
um,
okay,
I saw this whole article on,
um,
these drummers favorite like
prog rock bands from the 70s and,
uh, you know, early genesis, you know,
and Peter Gabriel is still in it and
Phil Collins was on drums, King Crimson,
all of these bands. So I actually started
listening to King Crimson, that band,
that album red. And, uh, it's
pretty fucking out there.
This shit is pretty fucking out there.
Some of it doesn't hold up,
some of it does,
but when they get into the real trippy
keyboard shit using all the effects and
everything, um, that definitely
gets a little bit nuts. But, uh,
I dunno, I was always curious of
like, Bill Bruford strumming and like,
he was always on, you know, the cover of
those magazines. I know he played in yes.
And all that stuff.
He's this amazing drummer,
so it was kind of psyched to finally
be able to hear him play. But, uh,
I don't know. I think I'm going
to listen to some of that shit,
if anybody has any good suggestions.
MMM.
I don't know. I can't help but feel
like it's very hipstery a lot of that.
I don't get it to PR progressive. I
don't mind fusion. Fusion is cool,
but progressive gets a
little, uh, you know,
reminds me of Kevin Murphy wants
with what? Kevin Murphy listens to.
One F is for family. So I'll just
treat it as like research or whenever.
All right, I'm babbling
here. I'm, once again,
thanks to everyone's going to come
out to my show Sunday night. And uh,
thanks to everybody on a front runner,
they gave me a part here in this movie.
I had such a great time on the shoot.
Met a bunch of people,
just awesome people and um,
okay.
I'm really excited to get back to my and,
and just enjoy the holidays
and everything. This is a
great time of fucking year.
You know, it would have been nice that
I could have said that without cursing,
but I'm not the brightest guy. All
right, go fuck yourselves. Go Celtics,
go patriots. Go Bruins. I
Dunno if we have a soccer team.
I don't know what it is, but I'm
just, that's it. Man, I'm going home,
I'm putting on my fucking pajamas and
ain't doing shit for the rest of the
fucking year except Christmas shopping
and cooking, thanksgiving dinner,
flying back east,
meeting a bunch of relatives,
giving out gifts to the Alpha fucking
crisis. It's always busy, isn't it?
Who gives a shit? All right. Go fuck
yourselves. Have a great weekend.
Enjoy the music here. And uh, also,
um, we got another 30 minutes.
If you knew of my podcast,
we always played like a greatest hits
from a Thursday afternoon podcast. Uh,
you know, from a few years ago. Maybe this
year. I don't fucking know. All right,
let's see.
Yeah,
you can be the best
it's
going on. It is a bill burr and it is
the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
November 9th, 2009. And yes,
I am a little late with this one.
It is a well into Monday evening
here in Los Angeles. And uh,
I had, I just had a whirlwind
of a week. I really did.
I really did.
It should have been my,
my basically my Wednesday,
Thursday, Friday, Saturday,
Sunday, my last whatever that is,
five days should have been filmed.
Okay.
With like that MTV style where just as
you start to focus on what the images,
they fucking quickly cut to what you
were just looking at from the side in a
black and black and white, you
know, you know what you're about.
They used to film up punked and Ashton
Kutcher would be standing there like,
okay, check it out. I'm fucking zippy.
Sea Crest is going to get a glazed
doughnut. Right. And then Bam.
Then they go from the side and he'd
be fucking sitting there with his hat
sideways. Remember that I had like
a fucking, I had, I had an, I had,
I had like a totally TRL experience.
I had an unbelievable fucking week,
you know? Why do I feel like what?
I actually feel guilty about it like
telling you guys that had an unbelievable
week. Like I have to fucking apologize
to you guys during a free podcast.
Fuck you. You know, I got to tone it
down. What? Cause your week sucked.
Why can't you be happy for me?
Why did I turn the fucking fan on?
It's God damn hottest fucking hell in
order. It is about my apartment. No, Bill,
what is it? Hang on a sec. Let me turn
this fucking thing on. Come on, turn on.
Um, the problem is is I
live in a desert and uh,
this time of year,
the sun is like three,
four hours where it just beats down
right on the corner of my apartment.
And, uh, it's just sitting there naked.
There's no avocado tree or a whatever,
a cactus or any shit to block out the sun.
So it just heats up like an oven.
And then I always try to close
the windows. You know, I've,
I've explained this before because I
say control out in the podcast and uh,
I want my neighbors to think
I'm a swell guy. No, I don't,
I don't give a shit what they
think. I just don't, you know,
if somebody steals something,
I don't want them to think it was me.
That's basically it. All right,
so this, this was my week.
Listen to this all you fuckers in your
cubicles. Ah, is it Tuesday morning,
the Grd?
Throw your hands up and give up on me
like I wasn't going to fucking do it this
week. Or at least today. Shame on you.
You could have been listening to this
yesterday. At the end of your job.
You know when you're supposed
to be getting all your
spreadsheets in order, Huh?
Right around the time that egg salad
sandwiches starting to bug you and you're
thinking,
can I,
can I shoot it right into the fucking
staples office chair that I'm sitting on
that sorta has some sort
of foam underneath it? Um,
isn't that the worst?
How would you have a sit down job and
you have a chair you can't fart into.
That's really bad.
You know what you've got and you've got
to wear like two pairs of boxers every
time you have Mexican, right? Jesus,
Bill, shit jokes. Three minutes. Right?
Right into the podcast. Huh? This
is how it was going to be. Sorry,
I was just adjusting myself here.
Not that kind of way.
Just adjust and everything cause I,
it's a long fucking story.
What you have to go through the turn
the fan on and keep the podcast going.
I have to stretch the technology
out all the wires. All right.
This was my week. Alright, Wednesday,
Wednesday I fly to a JFK
in New York City and um,
cause I'm getting ready
for my big town hall show,
my First Theater Gig in New York City,
right?
So I'm on my way there and I land right
around five 30 just in time for the
fucking traffic.
And low and behold,
the Yankees are playing games six of
the fucking world series. All right?
And if they win that night,
they're going to wrap the shit up.
I'm staying in a hotel in Times
Square. I bring my girl along, right?
It's a big fucking weak for me, you know?
And I'm sitting there riding and going,
please let the Phillies win. Please
let the fucking Phillies win. You know?
And then when game seven so I can walk,
watch all those fucking sad sack Yankee
fans with those satin Yankee jackets
that they wear.
You know,
like they're in some biker gang
on fucking happy days. I don't,
they're like one of the only teams left.
It's still has those satin jackets.
Um, anyways, but it was not to be right.
Then I started to watch games six and
Pedro's on the mound and he starts off
with like an 84 mile an hour fast ball
and it just really had a bad feeling that
I was going to watch the end of his career
that night and he was going to let up
like 17 Ronson. I couldn't watch
it so I shut it off. So, uh,
I have to do opie and Anthony in
the morning, so I take my vitamins,
I go to sleep or whatever.
Uh,
try not to get sick on the road and
right around right around right as I'm
starting to nod off,
I hear the first
okay.
Screaming that I would hear
for the next three hours.
I just hear like way off,
you know,
basically where I'm sitting in Times
Square is about a half a block away.
So all I hear right is not about rate
and nod off and get a nice eight hours
sleep.
Right before I go to do the morning radio.
All of a sudden I just
hear like [inaudible]
Yeah,
look at 27
woo.
Right? Couldn't really make
it out. Wasn't that clear?
And then I started hearing from her father
started horns blowing and it was like
the whole fucking stadium. I guess they
want it. I figured it out at that point.
That's like the whole fucking
stadium decided, what do we do now?
Let's go to time square and keep bill
up for the next fucking three hours.
And that's what they did. And it
was so loud. It's so ridiculous.
I was actually sitting there
with my head in between two pillows
like I was having a fucking like,
like a head sandwich. Right? It was
so fucking loud and so ridiculous.
I was actually laying there laughing.
Um, and what are the fucking odds, right?
One of the,
one of the biggest red sox fans,
one of the guys who hates the Yankees
the most. Okay. I live 3000 miles away.
What are the fucking odds?
There's one random day I'm going to fly
in and they're going to win the world
series and that is going to decide to
celebrate half a fucking block away.
So, uh, that was my first night. Um,
and the next night I did a Gig for a,
actually I didn't highlight
this gig because I was
trying to sell tickets for my
town hall Gig.
And um,
I actually on Thursday I opened for this
up and coming comedian that I'm sure
all you guys [inaudible] you got to know
about soon a guy by the name of Dane
Cook. I don't know if you've ever
heard of him. Just uh, you know,
up and coming guy, you know,
just, just trying to plug away,
I opened up for him at Madison Square
Garden, I a 10 minutes and it was,
wasn't like the, the, the
theater at Madison Square Garden.
It was where the next play and I'm trying
to think the last time I worked with
him on the road,
I think maybe we did a college
gig together about 15 years ago.
Way Back when we were starting out in
Boston. So it was, uh, I gotta tell Ya,
it's been a long time since I did a gig
that wasn't like, if I do Letterman,
I get butterflies,
but it's been a long time since I've done
a standup gig where I got that wasn't
going to be on TV and I
actually got butterflies. I, uh,
I was standing back there
waiting to go on and I was like,
legitimately
not like nervous to the point that
there was going to fuck with my set,
but I was like,
I don't know what it was.
I stumped because I kind of got to
this like Madison Sky Canyon and uh,
fortunately I had the presence of
mind to be like, you know what?
When are you ever going to get to do this
again, bill? I'm going to go with never,
I'm going to bet I'm going to pet the
long shot on this one and guess what?
You're never going to get to do this
again. So, uh, or most likely, you know,
never say never.
So why don't you go up there and fucking
enjoy it and right before Dan does is
shows in the round.
So it's like 20,000 fucking people and
I'm sitting there looking at the stage
and I'm trying to figure out
who am I going to look at.
So fortunately before I
went out there, I go, Dan,
exactly how does this theater in the
round work? And he goes, it's no big deal.
He goes, it's just like, it's like four
theaters. There's one in front of you,
one of the right, one of the left and one
behind Ya. Just break it up like that.
Then all of a sudden it didn't, it, it
just made sense. And I went out there,
he actually had a great car.
I mean I was freaking out.
I knew I was going to be doing the Gig
for about six days and I was just going
along,
my God,
is this going to be a bunch of Facebook
hotties and I'm going to go up there
saying [inaudible] every other word and
they're just going to be looking at me
like Wednesday and coming on, this
guy is angry. But they weren't.
They were fucking awesome and
they totally listened. And, uh,
I was probably,
uh,
one of the best 10 minutes sets I
think I've ever had as far as, uh,
how many times you got to do a 10
minutes set and you get to look up at a
Stanley Cup champion banner,
you know,
by the way, why is Madison Square Garden?
Um, I'm not trying to be a dick here.
Why is it considered a basketball Mecca?
They always say that like a Michael
Jordan would go there. It's, you know,
it's a basketball Mecca.
Lebron James. It's,
it's a basketball and then we say that
it's a basketball Mecca. All right.
Now fans of the New York Knicks.
All right.
And you're a true fan right now if
you're still watching those bumps. Okay.
He going through a real rough patch.
Um, I wanna I want you to justify,
send me an email and tell me,
explain to me how Madison Square Garden
is considered a basketball Mecca.
How,
okay.
The Knicks haven't won a
championship since 1972.
I think they won their
other one in like 69 or 70.
They've won two championships. The
fucking spurs have won. Like what?
Four five.
How is Madison Square Garden?
A basketball Mecca if that's a mecca.
What was the old Boston Garden?
We won 16 there.
Okay,
well say like the La Forum,
the La Forum,
they won a five, six, seven.
I don't know what they want their, they
want a good, they weren't like nine.
I think they won nine out there. Okay. If,
if if Madison Square Garden, I'm not
gonna, I'm not being a dick here.
New York City is a
basketball Mecca that wow,
a Rutger park or whatever the
fuck it is with a goat. Right?
He used to fucking, uh, uh,
lift up a refrigerator and put it on top
of the back board is not how the year
the urban myth goes or whatever the
fuck it was. Lew Alcindor. Right.
All those guys came from
there. I understand that. I
understand all those players,
but there's only been the fuck,
there's two championship banners
hanging in Madison Square Garden. Okay.
So I'm going to kind of be a jerk here
and say that it's not a basketball Mecca.
I don't think you've earned the
right, what? College basketball maybe,
you know, I dunno. I think you'll like it.
I think you guys really
need to win a lot more.
The fucking Chicago Bulls
when six in the 90s well,
it's the first three at old Chicago
Stadium and then the other three.
What at the United Center? Is that how
it went? I don't, I don't fucking know.
All I'm saying is, uh, you guys need to
bring that down a little bit. You know,
that's like you ever see like when
you see a restaurant, they, they,
they'll say a welcome to
two world famous blah, blah,
blahs. And you sit in there really,
really, they know about this in Portugal.
They don't, you're just saying
that and I think that fucking,
you know what Madison Square Garden is
just like Ray's famous pizza in New York
City.
Every fucking one claims to be.
Yeah,
there's a couple of co, there's a
couple of comedy clubs. The Ward,
the world famous fucking Yuk, Yuk, slap
a knee, whatever the fuck they call them.
It's like, it's not world
famous. It's not alright.
It isn't okay. Did I did? I
did. I beat that to death.
I really got off the rails here.
Let me get back to my fucking story here.
All right.
Um,
so the first night I go Yankees won the
world series and their fans keep me up,
um, for like three hours.
All right. And uh, oh,
I actually congratulated the Yankees
on, uh, on the radio the next day,
which is probably very surprising to a
lot of people if you'd like to hear it.
Go to the Wa just Google Bill Burr
Opie and Anthony show a Yankee rant.
For some reason they called it a rant,
but I was actually congratulating them
and I met everything that I said and it
might've sounded like I was being
a little sarcastic, but I wasn't.
Anyways,
let me plow ahead.
So the next night I opened for Dane
at Madison Square Garden, right?
I'm fucking is pictures of like
Frank Sinatra and, and an Elvis,
I'm talking to the security guard
has been there for 40 years.
He's pointing out where Mike Milbury went
into the stands and beat that guy with
his own fucking shoe. Right? The guys
ever seen that. And of course not.
You're not hockey fans.
Actually look,
look up Boston Bruins fight fans.
Just look that up.
There's a Bruins rangers game and
I think it was Terry O'Reilly.
Somebody grabbed this stick and they
hit him with it thinking, you know,
typical fan, like the,
like, that's not a real guy.
He's on skates. I have fucking chuck
Taylor's on. He can't catch me.
I don't know how he did it,
but Terry Riley climbed up the fucking
glass and grab this guy and then the rest
of the Bruins followed him
in the stands. And, um,
this is how far we've come as a society.
Back then.
That was probably a story for about five
days. There were lawsuits or whatever,
but you never heard about, there was no
fucking ESPN. It was ed came and it went,
there wasn't suspended
for life, you know? No.
Latrell Sprewell kind of shit.
Nothing. They went up there,
they beat fans with their own clothing,
and then they went back on the ice and
they finish the fucking game as far as I
know. Um, anyway, so
then Friday night I, uh,
I did my first theater Gig and I
want to thank everybody who came out.
There was a huge milestone in my career
to be able to perform in a theater in
New York City and sell the thing
out. Um, everything went awesome.
I got a standing ovation and, um, had, uh,
three killer comics on in front
of me, Joe De Rosa, Paul Versey,
and then there was this girl,
this contest winner.
And of course her name escapes me at this
point because I talk on my cell phone
too much and I can't remember
any fucking thing anymore. Oh.
And speaking of that Shit,
uh, not, I'll stay on track,
they'll stay on track because I was
making a couple of corrections from last
week. But, uh,
so Saturday night comes Saturday
night I was up in Boston,
I did the comics,
come home with a cam,
Elian Denis leary and
all that type of shit.
And that was in front of 6,000 people.
So basically over three days I went
on in front of a almost 25,000 people.
And,
uh,
now I'm sitting in my bedroom talking
to myself and do an orange fucking
microphone. So you know, I'm coming down
a little bit, getting back to reality,
you know, how's that for a fucking
weekend? I can't believe it.
Unbelievable. I can't believe it.
And then he says unbelievable.
Just in case you didn't realize
that it was unbelievable right now.
You know what's funny about me? I'm
actually self conscious right now that a,
I talked about so much good shit
that happened to me. That's,
that's what it's like to be a fucking
German Irish Catholic from Boston.
That's what it is. Oh my God. A bunch of
good stuff happened. I should feel guilty,
you know? And I almost said, fuck you
to you guys. Like you're actually,
you give a shit. Either way. I really
got issues. All right, let's uh,
let's make a couple of corrections. All
right. Last week, that racist movie,
I was trying to remember the name of it's
birth of a nation and I want to thank
the 87 people who brought
that to my attention.
And I also mentioned I was going to
read a book about how to speak better on
stage using,
using my voice correctly.
And people wanted to know the name of
the book that I was reading actually lied
to you. I'm not reading it.
I keep starting the book,
but it's really involved.
It's just select your daughter from
his emotional and you're never bored.
And I'm just like, oh
my God, I hate school.
And then I close it and then I'll read
like slashes autobiography or like,
what's the guy from the red hot
chili peppers? Anthony Kiedis.
I'm sort of skipping around his biography.
Um,
but the name of the book is called
freeing the natural voice by Kristen link
ladder.
Yeah.
All right. L I. N. K. L. A. T. E. R. M.
I just been doing a lot of shows and a,
I have a tendency to yell from my throat
rather than down here by the fucking
diaphragm. You liked it here? That
that's fucking Ray's famous pizza.
That's an awful burger from a diner.
And that's uh,
some bar pizza that I got up in
Boston trying so hard to get in shape.
I just don't think it's going to happen.
Fuck that pat.
The whole fucking goddamn summer
to get in shape and I didn't do it.
I've been a fucking idiot like
usual and waiting til the last week,
like one of these chicks on the
shows right now. I just don't eat.
Then I show up in a strapless
dress with my fucking, my fucking,
I was just say clavicle showing. Is that
set though? Is that a word? Collarbone.
There you go.
What does the clavicle,
is that that thing on your
back that looks like a sale.
What is that your shoulder blade?
Is that call the clavicle?
I don't fucking remember when it radius
Ulna. Tarsal metatarsal Phalanges.
Um, anyways, let's uh, let's
plow ahead here with the podcast.
So I'm actually now I'm like hardcore.
There's no turning back.
I have to drop like 10 pounds before my
special or my big fucking TV kitchen,
kitchen, TV sized head is going
to look fucking ridiculous on TV.
So I really got it.
I got to get the booze weight off and
I'm actually just went for a bike ride.
Um, I was hiking up one of these parks
out here, out here, Griffith Park,
you know the observatory. Did you guys
ever see a, that James Dean movie?
Then he filmed something up
there or Charlie's angels.
And when those four skinny whores are up
there with their botox in their fucking
twats hanging out, remember that last
scene that, that, that's the observatory.
So the other day I was hiking up to it
on foot and I see this fucking like 55
year old guy,
white hair pedaling up the hill.
Like he's in a fucking Viagra commercial.
And I'd go look at that son of a bitch.
You know, when he had all the,
all the, he had all these sheep,
he had the whole getup on, you know,
the whole Lance Armstrong outfit.
Like he's gonna,
you know,
ride through Paris and throw his hands
up right under the OCTA triumph. Right.
Rather than, he's just riding up
a hill in the middle of a desert,
sucking in bus fucking fumes. But I was
impressed and I was like, you know what,
if that old bastard can do it,
you know, and I got to admit,
55 in La is like 32.
The way these people work out out here.
All right. And, uh,
I'm sorry to the people in the middle
of the middle of this country and a down
south. All right. I just love
it. People do that when they,
when they insult you and then they say
they're sorry, but you know, they're not,
you know,
I get that a lot at the end of my
show is I didn't think you were funny.
You know? I mean, I'm sorry I
didn't, and I'm always like, okay,
yeah, yeah. Cause you know, it's
like, I know other people did,
but you know, it's like, you know,
I'm sorry, I just, I just didn't,
why do you keep a pile? You're
not sorry. You're not sorry. Okay.
I got it.
You don't like me and I don't give a shit
because you already paid for a ticket.
You paid to watch me ignore you.
And I find that I find that humorous.
Um, and he was, let's plow ahead.
So I figured I gave myself 10 days to be
able to fucking make it all the way up
to this Goddamn Hill and uh,
just did it today and it made
it all the way up to the top.
I'm not gonna lie to Ya. I feel like
I'm going to fucking die. But I, uh,
I actually made it up there.
So now I don't know what to do.
I thought that that was going to be my
project. I would just do that every day.
And every day I get a little bit farther.
And while I would focus on
the carrot in front of me,
I would just drop this booze weight,
right?
But what happens the first fucking day?
I go all the way up the God damn thing.
It's now what do I do?
You know what I gotta do?
I got to join a gym and I
got a Tro to weights around.
That's what I got to do. You
know what? In the mail today,
I got a free 30 days at Gold's gym.
Anybody work at a gym?
How was this free?
30 days going to work out for me.
Sign up for three 30 for free.
I can't even fucking talk.
The Hell is wrong with me.
I know what's wrong with me.
I fucking flown like 200 hours on a
plane the last goddamn two months.
You should have seen this fucking douche
bag putting his coat in the overhead
compartment on my flight out here.
I couldn't tell if this guy had the
biggest Yamaka on I'd ever seen in my life
or he had just shrunk his jazz hat,
you know,
you know those little jazz hats that
those black guys were and then the white
guys were when when they get into jazz
to try to act like they get it to,
you know those ones, they're the
little African colors, you know,
and you just sit there and
talking about a Charlie Parker,
you know, and your version of salt
peanuts or whatever the fuck it is.
And
I don't know what it was.
Any Jewish people listen to
this shit? Huh? Let me ask you a question.
Is it technically still a Yamaka when
it almost goes to the front of the guys
hairline in all the way to the two ways.
I mean, this thing, it looked like a,
like a, what does that thing
the Mexicans do? They use the,
uh, the Tortilla, right?
How fucking ignorant and I have
every goddamn culture out there.
I thought a Yamaka was, it was
a beanie. Is that incorrect?
I call him a beanie for a long time and
I always used to get looks. I was like,
yeah, the guy had the fuck and
I had the fucking beanie thing,
the a and then I get looks and it's
like, oh, it's cause I cursed. That's I,
I say fuck when I'm trying to gather
my thoughts sometimes the fucking, uh,
beanie rather than saying the, um, Oh gee,
what is that thing called the beanie?
I put the fucking in front of it
and then it adds an extra edge to it
inadvertently. And people like, oh my God,
he doesn't like Jewish people with hats.
Um,
is it a beanie or as a beanie?
That thing with the little propeller
on top of it and another question.
Did anybody ever have those?
Does anybody old enough to actually
answer that fucking question?
Is that one of those Hollywood things,
cartoon things that they just acted like
people used to have those back in the
day, I know kids used to wear
those little raccoon hats.
You know back when there
was game all over the place.
You know mothers made pies and
stuck them on window sills.
Stanley, if you're going to
shoot it, you bet it cook it.
We're going to have to eat it.
Right?
The white people ever say
that or did we just waste?
Have we always just wasted shit?
We've always had the MTV
cribs approach to fucking nature
having way white people didn't.
Buffalo bill used to just ride
around shooting buffalo in the head,
laughing his ass off to that Fu Manchu
that connected to his sideburns. You know
what? How much more did you increase
your odds of having your leg sold off,
sold off, sought off
what you drank, brandy,
if you had that little
fucking that Fu Manchu,
what does that one called as far as the
facial hair masking? A lot of questions.
Maybe I should have done some research.
The only person I've seen with that is
that Guy Lemmy from Motorhead and then
afterwards, the dude from Metallica
had it. He had it for a minute there.
James Hetfield,
why don't we get to the questions here?
I seem to be asking a
lot of questions here.
Why don't I get to some of your questions
and I'll try to answer them a question.
Bill,
I have two questions.
I can't help but notice these fucking
annoying commercials and ads about selling
your gold.
Um,
I wondered whether or not you thought
this was a conspiracy to round up all the
gold still owned by individuals so
that when the dollar completely tanks,
the people won't have anything
of worth for themselves. Uh, no,
I don't think it's a conspiracy.
I just think that those guys late night
are doing a much smaller version of the
scam that bankers did originally is
what they're doing is they're taking,
and they're just giving people
a piece of paper for it.
But it's not as bad as when the
banks, the banks did it. They said,
give us your gold and we'll give you
these little pieces of paper that are
redeemable anytime you want,
you can come back and get your gold.
And needless to say, eventually, uh, you
couldn't claim your gold anymore. And uh,
they just sort of cap it.
Okay.
No one knows where it is cause
you can't audit them. Um, so yeah,
that's what those guys are doing.
They're anticipating I probably the
tanking of the dollar, they get the,
I don't know if you guys,
have you seen those commercials
where they're just like,
I just do a bit about it. You
know, if you got an old class ring,
if you've got a broken bracelet,
if you got some busted jewelry,
sandy in your gold and we will give you
cash for it, that's what they're doing.
Um, and for those of you
think I'm a fucking moron,
if you had a sandwich shop and somebody
walked in and tried to buy a sandwich
sandwich with some rubles,
you tell him to go fuck themselves.
But if somebody who came from a country
that used to use rubles but at a handful
of gold, you know, you still would
be like, dude, what the fuck?
I don't know what gold is trading it,
but you'd know that the gold had value.
Okay. That's the great thing about
gold all around the fucking world.
You can get yourself a god damn sandwich
with a piece of gold. I challenge you
to buy anything with the fucking
ruble. Go ahead and do it. Um,
or some defunct the yen. Did they
have that anymore in Japan? Bill,
you're getting in over your head. Shut
the fuck up. Just keep moving. So no,
I don't think that that's a conspiracy.
I just think that that's one of the
oldest scams in the book. And uh,
JP Morgan and the guys had,
was it Jekyll's island or
whatever? Federal Reserve.
Those guys perfected it.
God bless him. Shame on us.
Fool me once. Shame on you. Fool us
for fucking a hundred years and a yeah,
we're fucking morons. Okay, next one. Um,
also I'll be coming to Cleveland to see
you and wondered if the same guy that
opened for you in Pittsburgh, we'll be
offering for you in Cleveland as well.
Um,
okay.
Oh, that was Doug Synn. Yay. Doug. Seen
Yay. Getting some props. Ducks in. Yeas.
Hilarious. I kind of rotate my
openers. Um, when I go to Cleveland,
who's it going to be?
Ryan Dalton and Jason Law head.
Actually a two guys that I've known
for about five years right now.
They're based out of Cleveland. Travel
all around. Absolutely fucking hilarious.
And A, I lose half my liver every time
I go out there and work with them.
So I love those guys and they're going
to be open and they're fucking hilarious.
So, uh, if you're wondering if I'm going
to have a funny opener. Yes, I am. Um,
next question.
Bill is a say of bills and the Sabres fan.
I think I have it the worst with two lost
Stanley cups and for lost super bowls.
And 11 years, 11 years without a playoff
appearance. Do you think I'm right?
No, I don't. I do not. I think you
definitely have it bad. But um,
for the longest time everybody talked
Boston and then we won a bunch of shit.
So that was over.
And they have been talking about the
cubs Blahblahblahblahblah but I think the
worst city to be a fan in
right now is Cleveland.
Very quietly.
Those guys have gone my entire
life and nobody has won anything.
The Cleveland browns have
never won a super bowl.
The Cleveland Cavaliers have
never won an NBA championship.
And the Cleveland Indians haven't
won a world series since 1948 so,
and less your in your seventies.
Okay.
Um, for all extensive purposes, the
Indians have never won a world series.
Do you understand that? Cause you gotta
be like at least like eight years old,
nine years old to remember
a fucking world series.
Now some douche bags going to email me.
Actually always chicks do your job when
the Tigers won it in [inaudible] 68 who
gives a fuck? You know what
I'm saying? Don't be a cunt.
All right. Um, so I would
say that they have it worse.
Um, but yeah, you guys are,
you know, you're right there.
You're right there with them. That's
one of those things. It's like,
do you really want to win that argument?
Remember long time ESPN, long time ago,
ESPN did, who has the,
who had the worst curse,
the Boston red sox or the Chicago cubs
and they did this stupid trial and they
had like George Wendt from cheers who's
a Chicago guy. He's arguing to be like,
no, we're more miserable. And
it's just like, all right,
you want to win that contest?
That's all you.
Who the fuck would want to win the
misery contest? It's really beyond me.
So congratulations. You didn't win it.
I think people in, uh, Cleveland, um,
our world, I think, how do
you think those guys feel?
Have to fucking guys with world series
rings this year. It used to be, uh,
used to be on the fucking Indians were
half the guys in the world series, right?
Cc Sabathia. Ah, fuck.
Who was the other guy? God dammit,
I had them right at the tip.
I got to stop talking on my cell phone.
Manny Ramirez.
Okay. We'll see how the last couple of
years, Manny Ramirez, red sox bought him,
right cc Sabathia the fucking a Yankees
bought that dude via the brewers.
Who else did, Jim told me play
on the Phillies last year.
Yeah.
I mean the Indian should've won it.
They should have won it.
But the way baseball is is a, you
know, it's not competitive anymore.
That's why I'm kind of a,
I think I'm tapping out on baseball.
I don't give a shit anymore. Uh, I dunno.
In my world competition, I
was right. Actually wrote an
email to a guy about this.
I met my world. Competition is our
best guys. First. Your best guys,
best team wins.
That's to me is competition.
I don't think competition is our
best guys. Plus your best guys,
verse whatever the Fuck you
have left. Stupid. You know,
she met when you were kids and you'll
be choosing up sides, you know,
and right off the bat of two of the best
guys were on the same side or in the
end it seemed uneven.
People feel,
and when I was from, and it was
called smug teams, Smu, see k,
I've never heard that anywhere else. I
was like, suck with an eminent snuck.
People ignore smoke.
TMZ teams are smug. Hey,
what the fuck that's,
that should have been said like
during the little rascals era,
but some reason it was said during
my childhood digs a smug teams.
So then you had to break them up.
You had to break up the evil empire,
the fucking, the fucking Yankees
or the red sox Dodgers or whatever.
Any one of these teams. I mean the, the
Yankees are in a league of their own,
but you know what I'm saying?
Red Sox and all them are just as
much part of the fucking problem.
They would break up any of those kids
know enough to break up those fucking
teams. All right. Anyways, plowing ahead.
Um, let's read, uh,
what the fuck was I going to read here?
Um,
questions. I already did this.
This is called broads over
there. Broads over there.
I don't know what the hell it
says. Let's read this one. Bill.
I had been a fan of yours sometime.
Just want to tell you that.
I think you're a great thank you.
Why don't I fucking delete those?
I think your comedy of up to put the
all right.
Anyways, the reason I am writing you
is to tell you a funny story. Uh,
my girl dating five plus years
now and I live in Tucson,
Arizona and she's always bitching at me
saying, we never do anything anymore.
Well, my job is very consuming of my
time and I realized that she was correct.
So what do I do?
So what I do is I try to come up with
something we could do together that would
be entertaining and unique,
something different that is not
an average night out in Tucson se.
The guy's using his brain,
trying to surprise her. Anyways,
I've been telling her about your comedy
and showing her clips of you, uh,
that I found on your myspace
page for the past few months.
She really seemed to enjoy
it and laughed hysterically.
So I planned this great evening
for the 20th of November. Um,
which goes something like this,
head up to temp Eav,
have a nice dinner and head over to the
Improv and watch your show a your eight
o'clock show.
Um,
while I bought the tickets and thought I
would surprise her with the whole thing,
she loved the idea and she
was very excited and I was
pleased to see her excited
about the event.
Well,
we were telling our friends about
it and she sort of says this, well,
it's his evening and I'm just
thought of tagging along. Uh,
I got to admit that,
um,
I was a little upset at this point because
I intended this whole thing to be a
gift from me to her,
which is funny because this is very
similar to the story that you told on
October 19 on the October 19th podcasts
when you took your girl in the corvette
up the PCH.
She just sort of shut a,
she just showed it sort of shut me down.
Um,
so my question to you is
why is it never enough?
Ah,
what a great question.
Do you realize you just asked the question
of properly every guy on this fucking
podcast. Um, hold on.
I'm just going to pause here while
the women rolled their eyes and I go,
that's bullshit. That's
not true. It's just you.
You got to use your imagination.
What did like surprises?
They just fucking
shut up.
Just shut up.
What'd you do?
You just shut up and take off all those
fucking layers. It's not the 18 hundreds,
you know,
with your panties and your panty hose
and your slip and you're fucking skirt.
All right. What am I talking
about? I Dunno. Um, anyways,
uh, I lost my place. So
my question to you is,
why is it never enough?
I can do everything she wants,
but she was still find a way to make
me look like an asshole. Making me a,
making it seem like I'm dragging her
around and making her do all that stuff
that I want to do.
I guess that is why I relate to your
comedy because it seems that she is only
happy when we do all the things that she
wants to do. Uh, you don't want to talk,
you don't want to talk about with Brunch
Street Fairs in the candle store. Uh,
nevertheless, we are going
and really looking forward
to seeing you in person. Uh,
I hope to see you have to show selling
some cds and DVDs. All right. Um,
why is it never enough? I
don't know. I don't know why.
I don't know if it's an
insecurity that they are,
they're always questioning whether
you truly love them or not.
Um,
I have no idea.
I don't know why. I mean, I would think
okay.
That, all right. Look, look,
look at me. Okay. I want it.
I rented a corvette for the day,
core Vectren verbal and I
drove my girl all around La.
We went up the fucking Pacific
coast highway, looked at
the ocean, we had lunch.
I took her out to this
beautiful bar late at night.
I drove through the Hollywood hills
with the top down, looking at the stars,
looking at the lights out over the city.
I thought it was a very romantic thing.
And then I got on the podcast and she was
just like, yeah, that was really just,
that was really your thing. I
just did that for you. You know,
I just thought of that there
in a $70,000 automobile,
you know,
seeing views that people fly six
hours to see and just, you know,
just got a free lunch out of it and
free fucking drinks and you have a watch
surprises right there.
You just spit on my own microphone.
You ever had a price is right. You
have watched the prices, right? Sure.
We all have. Okay. Getting
a corvette, I mean like,
and then go into that
restaurant and driving up to
PCH and looking at the lights
and going up to the fucking bar in
the hotel with John Belushi. Oh, deed.
Isn't that, that sounds like one of
one of those showcases. She's like,
get your bid on. Are you going to bid?
Oh, you're going to pass, you know?
Oh Dude. You know what? Speaking
of that, I was watching,
I was watching the prices
right the other day and uh,
I had like a white guilt
moment. Okay, this,
this black dude goes up to go spin
the big fucking wheel, all right?
And you know, you know, deal. If for those
of you who don't live in this country,
you basically,
you spin the wheel,
whoever comes close to a dot closest to
a dollar without going over guests to
then go on and bid on the big surprises,
all right?
That's for people in England and Australia
and all that shit who email me if you
don't know the show.
So basically
they have every denomination from 5 cents,
10 cents,
1530 40,
45 50 55 60 all the way up to $1.
So this like 55 year old black dude
spins the wheel and it stops on 30 cents.
Okay?
Now you can decide to stay or spin again.
Now I'm not a fucking math
petition, but I think, uh,
you want to hit on 30 cents, right? You
want it? He's looking out at the crowd.
I'm like, is this guy fucking kidding
me? And I'm kind of laughing going,
all right? He's a little bit old.
He's a little bit older, right?
His family's going to straighten it out
for him and he looks out in the crowd.
I don't know if they told them.
I don't know what the fuck they told him,
but he goes,
I'm going to stay.
He stayed on 30 cents and I'm looking
at drew Carey going like, all right,
I know what Bob Barker would do. Bob
Barker would be like, okay, wait a minute.
You sure you want to stay on this?
30 cents is really low.
He would have helped him through it,
but drew Carey just went like,
he's going to stay on 30 cents. All
right, let's bring up the next person.
So the dude is standing there with the
30 cents up above them and I wanted to
laugh my ass off and be like,
what a stupid fuck.
But then I felt guilty because it was a
black dude and I'd be white laughing at
this black guy. Like he's a
moron and that's one of the best.
The worst thing about racists is a ruined
your ability to be able to laugh at a
moron
because he's another color.
Then all because it's all of a sudden
it becomes this ugly thing. You know,
I give a fuck what color you are.
If you're playing a game,
we are trying to come close to a
dollar and you stop at 30 cents,
you're a fucking moron.
And I should be able to laugh.
And I was laughing and then I felt bad.
And then I actually thought, oh shit,
someone's going to take that clip and
they're going to put it up on youtube and
then someone's going to write a bunch
of racist shit underneath it rather than
sticking with the subject
that this individual who
happens to be a black dude is
a fucking moron,
you know?
Or at the very least didn't understand
how the game worked. Look at that.
I had to get, still had to give
him the benefit of the doubt,
a fucking game show that's
been on 40 fucking years. Um,
Jesus Christ. How did I get on that
subject? All right, let's get back here.
So my question is why is it never enough?
You know what?
My girls got the flu right now.
How funny would it be if I actually called
her in here right now with the flu to
ask her this question.
I'm really jeopardizing my relationship.
Should I do it everybody? I think I'm
going to do it. Hang on one second.
Let me see if I can get
her in here. Hold on. Amia.
Yeah.
Alright. She's coming
in. Don't say anything.
I'm watching miss finessed
my way through this. Yeah,
it's come on in for a second.
Alright. Making her way in.
Ladies and gentlemen, making her
triumphant return to the podcast.
Look at you. You're officially
sick. Officially sick pajamas,
socks. Is that orange juice
or you got any booze in there?
Okay. Yes it is everything.
Don't worry Cleo. We'll get it.
All right. Here's a question for you.
Here's a question one of my listeners had.
All right,
I'm not trying to be hostile here.
This is the female question.
I know we had a big battle about that
dude who punched that chick in the face,
right? Yes, we did. Rihanna,
Chris Brown and Chris Brown.
We had a big argument on the plane
about that. It's really bad. Um,
all right, so we talk about that
argument or should we get into this?
Why don't we get into this and then we'll
do the argument. Then we'll wrap it up.
Then we'll segue. There you go. All right.
I'll read this to you
and then you have to get,
we have to come closer to the mic
here. Um, don't look over my shoulder.
She reads way faster than me. It makes
me self conscious. All right. Basically,
there's this guy, he's got a
girl. I'm going to paraphrase.
My listeners don't have to
listen to this shit again. Um,
they'd been dating for five years.
She always complains that they never do
anything because the job is very time
consuming. He admits this is,
his job is very time consuming.
Okay. All right. We're on the same
page. We're ready to go. Okay. Listen,
she starts coughing.
Don't make me,
I've been doing this door everyday,
all day long. I make a lab,
so she starts coughing.
You're terrible. She's like,
oh, listen to you. Suddenly
he's selling. You worked in a mine.
Listen to that. That's horrible.
God, how did I ever find you
attractive? Oh my God, I'm
choking you. No, I'm joking.
I told you are adorable. All Right, nice.
Any easy, easy. She says,
Oh my God, this is horrible.
You sound horrible.
I'm listening. All right. Stop doing that.
Be a performer here. Okay. All right.
Jerry Lewis would have just suck down.
Um,
anyways lady.
See what a great sense of humor she's
got even with 105 degree. So no,
it's not that he doesn't take her,
she say,
she just said he doesn't take her
anyway. Do you understand that? Yes,
I understand. Okay. He
has a time consuming job.
She complains that they
don't go a lot of places.
She's claiming that they don't go anywhere
and he admits that he works a lot and
might not have enough time here.
Okay.
Just don't side with the broad cause she
has a Twat here. All right. Really? Yeah,
I know I had to go there. It makes
the guys laugh. All right. Uh,
so anyways,
so then he just,
so he decides he's going to take her
somewhere so he sees that I'm going to be
common in town. Right. He starts showing
clips of me, uh, my, my space page.
Of course she starts laughing cause I'm
fucking hilarious, right? We know this.
And Hanson. Thank you. All right. So
he goes, all right, this is perfect.
So he gets tickets to
my eight o'clock show.
He's going to take her out to dinner,
he's going to take her out to the comedy
show. She says, that's not a good idea.
He says, yeah, till we site. He
feels like he's fixed the problem.
So the next night they're talking
about it to their friends and uh,
he says where he's going to go
and what they're going to do,
what should we have done and what
shouldn't. We do? Remember that?
No reservoir dogs. Oh yeah, totally.
Like telling jokes are Gig when like
a bunch of girls in a school yard.
Um, sorry. I know. I
do bad impressions. Um,
terrible, terrible. I know.
So, uh, anyway, so then he
finally ends up saying it to,
uh, he brings it up. She brings it up in
front of her friends and she said, well,
it's his evening and I'm just sort of
tagging along. All right. And he's,
he goes,
I got to admit that I was a little upset
at that point because I intended this
whole evening thing to be a gift
from me to her. Okay. Right.
So he goes,
it reminded me of when you took your
girl out in the corvette and you said the
same thing, right? Yeah. So he says,
my question to you is
why is it never enough?
I don't think that it's okay. I
love it. Your tongue tied. Look at,
see what you're doing right now.
No.
Say what's your exact say
exactly what you're thinking.
Don't do this is you try to figure a way
to spin this shit. Don't spin it. Yeah.
I'm not spinning it because
it's not like it's not enough.
But I think where she's coming from,
it's not like
the whole
he get done. No, no,
no, no. I, like I said,
it comes from this point of insecurity
that you guys never feel loved enough.
Can he listened to me?
It's hard, but yeah. Okay.
He is a fan of yours first.
She,
she became a fan of yours but
he is like a long time fan. So,
even though she would enjoy
seeing your show, of course it's,
he has more of a connection to you
and your, your comedy than she does.
He has more invested because he's,
he likes you and she just heard of you
I guess when he introduced her to your
clips on youtube and stuff.
So in a way it's like,
oh well I like it and I'll show it to her
and now she thinks it's funny so we'll
make a night out of it. But it's not as
if, I don't know what else she likes.
I mean, I'm sure she likes
going shopping and whatnot.
So basically the fact that he didn't
say, he didn't say, Hey, you know what,
I have the afternoon free.
You want to like go to the farmer's
market or go like window shopping or
whatever. That would have been an
evening or an afternoon all about her.
That's like the difference. And
so can I interrupt right now? Yes.
It's a relationship. There's
two people. It's not a birthday.
Uh Huh.
I understand. If it's a birthday,
it's all about her. She goes,
you never take me anywhere.
So basically the problem here is
the place that he's taking her to,
he can actually have a good time at,
he should actually take her to
something that he doesn't want to do.
No,
I think the issue is that she would have
maybe preferred it if it was 100% all
about her.
Like if it was,
so you guys are selfish
specifically that she wanted to do?
I don't know if she saw for [inaudible].
Well, it sounds like she's a little,
she's being a little
bratty about it now though.
I'll take that. That was
very, I, you know what,
I appreciate that they know what the
fact that usually we actually admitted at
least to the, now I can
listen to your opinion. Yeah,
a lot more open mindedly okay.
Yes. Okay. I mean she's being a
little bratty to throw that in there,
especially to her friends.
But
what do you think I would do?
What do you,
what do you think I would do
if you did that? If, if you,
if you made that comment in front of your
friends. Okay. And then I've already,
I've, I've already stopped
talking to us. We're coming home.
All we hear is this silent were of her
Prius
C it starts off Julie Somehow.
Um, I don't think I was being bratty
though when I made the remark. I wasn't,
no,
I understand it now.
What it was was I love the
corvette long before I loved you.
So it really was something
more about me then.
Well, I don't as, as, as I
smiling too much that day. Is
that what bugged, you know,
listen,
as awesome as it was to ride in
a corvette down the PCH Malibu,
that was fucking amazing.
It was not the,
one of the things that I had on
my mind as something fun to do.
When you mentioned it, I was like, yeah,
that, that sounds awesome. We did it.
It was even better
and no, whoa, Whoa, Whoa, wait a minute.
As far as your days that you've had out
here in La, where does that one rank?
It's like number two to my birthday.
See?
Oh, random day in October. So
that was a fucking big time score.
And you still had to be like, wow, that
was really kind of your thing. Why?
Why would you do that?
You just said that I wasn't being
bratty when I sent it in and now you're,
now you're,
no, no, no, no. Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I have memory problems. Wait, what?
When did I say what? I wasn't, I sent,
you weren't being bratty with what
before?
I said,
I don't think that I was being bratty
when I said the thing about there and you
were like, no, no, no. I see where
I see where you're coming from.
You just said it and that's not what
I meant. Oh Great. How convenient.
Look at me.
I can't remember anything from,
I don't have any short term memory
anymore, so I don't know who that guy was.
Who was who. I don't even know if I
was agreeing with you. You know what?
I'm never taking the stand if I ever
kill anybody because I'm not going to be
able to
honesty. It was a nice thing
that you did and it was,
it was unnecessary for me to say that.
It wasn't that you guys
have to hang on a second.
Why kiss my sick girlfriend blah.
There you go.
It wasn't necessarily see that guys,
I didn't have to slap her around.
I didn't have to call any of them
names over there like Chris Brown.
Oh I know.
And it was unnecessary for her to say
that cause he was trying to do a nice
thing.
Yes he is more of a fan of you than she
is making it more of an better and more
interesting fun night for him than for
her even though she would have enjoyed it
but it was unnecessary.
No, not what most women just
automatically see that with the idea.
So then would she gets self conscious
and feel like she had to call [inaudible]
call it out before they said it would.
She may be say that because
she's kind of embarrassed
that th that that like, yeah like
cause if he said it, you know,
what are you doing? Oh he's taken me.
See this guy bill Barry says cunt,
every other word. That's what he's doing
on this romantic night. God Damn it.
I think she might be right.
You know what? Yeah, I bet. What
have happened was, oh, what did,
what does your boyfriend doing?
Oh, what are you guys doing? Oh,
we're going to dinner and then
we're going to a comedy show.
And I don't think that's necessarily the
first thing on a woman's mind when it
comes to a romantic evening.
Okay. Last question. Tell me,
you didn't feel like you were dating
Paul Newman when we were driving up the
fucking PCH with the top down.
That was pretty impressive. Uh,
you didn't feel like Nia
Woodward? I did. It did. Exactly.
It's a fucking great idea.
Ballet like ran up to us and we
pulled into the, uh, parking.
Oh and put it in a special spot.
And God pat back then underneath that,
that overhang. So the shade would be, was
be all nice and cool. It was pretty hot.
You know, they don't do that when you
pull up in the Prius, do they? No,
they do not stick that
bitch right out in the sun.
Um, all right. So let's, let's get, let's
get onto, let's get onto our argument.
So, right. We're, we're flying
back from New York City.
How amazing was I a town hall? You were
amazing. Standing Ovation. That's right.
If fucking right.
Amp,
how insecure my that I had to make
you say that for the sixth time you're
insecure, but I know exactly. All
right. So let's plow ahead here. Um,
so we're flying back from, uh, where
are we at Boston at that point.
Yeah. And uh, I don't,
I don't know if we'd already watched
the youtube clip or whatever.
Riana had gone on TV
talking to Diane Sawyer,
breaking it down. Yup.
Talking about, um, you know,
getting the shit kicked out of her by
that dude with the beaver teeth. Right.
He really looks like a bug to beaver.
He does.
He has no business being a pop star.
Um,
he bitter too. Right? Did, why wouldn't
you? You got to utilize your weapons.
So we're sitting there and it's this real,
it's this really sad interview and
she's just like, I just felt silly.
It's stupid. So to be,
so this is what I did.
So it started off as a joke and I
said, all right, this is my impression
because wrong.
All right,
go on record as saying that
I feel that this is so wrong.
It's so wrong. All right, well this is
the deal. I was talking about how they,
she was just saying that,
you know,
I found an inappropriate text message
and then things escalated and then next
thing you know, he caved in my cheek and
started biting me and Blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah. And I was
just like, you know what?
She left out a lot of the details and
cause what I've learned with arguing with
women is when women argue when you're
there or not winning or they're not
getting you to admit that you're wrong,
that some point they make this switch
in there where they're just like,
I'm just going to make this person as mad
as I possibly can by using every ounce
of information that I know about him.
So truth,
you know what? That's as
good as a, yes. Anyway,
so this is one of those in the moment
jokes, I can't remember what they said.
I said,
this is my impression of,
of the conversation before. I can't
remember what, how I did it though.
I was like,
wish you seen from Barbados but for some
reason I started doing this really bad
Jamaican accent and I good Yaman Yaman
who who'd be sending you the text man,
Yo fuck you bitch.
I ain't go say not Joe man who gave you
the text message you fucking buck tooth
to be,
I can't remember it somehow talked about
his teeth and you will laugh in your
fucking ass off.
I can never recreate that.
That's why I had to tap out and you
will laugh when you fucking ass off.
And it was totally wrong.
And,
but then like halfway through it,
I started making my point of how I'm so
sick of every time a woman gets the shit
kicked out of her, not every time, but
all of these women they always get,
they always get to show guys in that
bad light of all these guys who beat the
shit out of their women,
but they never show when women fuck
over guys ever in those situations ever.
Like, you know, the situations that I've
seen where, you know, a friend of mine,
you know,
she slammed the door into them and then
just called the cops and said that he
hit her and they without question, arrest
him and then that fucked up his job.
And now everybody looks at him like he's
a wife beater. He never even did it.
How come Oprah never does shows about
that? That was our big argument.
And then she somehow,
you know me the way I say shit,
some I would seem like I was advocating
that the guy did nothing wrong.
And you know, all women are
these horrible manipulative. Yes,
you're not, you're not horrible
manipulat preachers, but you guys,
you definitely manipulate.
Can I burn a joke here that,
that fucking milkshake joke up? Burn
it. I don't have that many listeners.
I'll still probably do it on my special.
I don't give a fuck.
So here's a little teaser,
kind of like when you see a movie trailer,
this is kind of a bit I'm
doing on my, uh, my special,
this is what my girlfriend did
one night when I was driving home.
This is how much they manipulate or as
I call it, lie to get what they want.
I was driving home and I
was looking at this fucking,
there was this diner and I was driving
home and it was late and I was like,
you know, hey, you know,
I'm gonna stop there.
I'm going to get one of those milkshakes.
And you would just like, oh my God,
fuck you. It's hilarious. Let's
not forget. At the end of the day,
my job is to like make those people
laugh. Okay, Nia, you don't understand.
These people work hard all week.
These were Americans.
They need to come out and forget
about their problems now, whatever.
I don't have one of my Mel Blanc.
I got one fucking voice. I do.
Nice reference. I watch cartoons. Really?
Is that all it takes to
impress you on a first date?
That's how you ended up with me.
He knows who does the voice of bugs bunny.
This guy is a keeper.
I think this guy will
be able to provide what
hung out when I hooked up.
We'll save that for another one.
But you got you gotta Tell Him, Huh?
You had to be impressed with my skills.
Well you see that they
just won't give it up.
This guy was fucking cock
blocking me on an Olympic level.
He saw I was going to hook up.
He actually tried to split a cab with you
on the way home and I got around that.
Got around that. What happened?
I fucking put the cards.
I went all in just like world series
of poker. I went all fucking in.
She, she was trying to be all coy with
the Little Sammy Davis Jr had on trying to
play all hard to get her thinking.
You were dealing with the
sophomore in fucking college.
Like I didn't have any fucking lines
and they're douchebag kept coming over,
cock blocking me. He invited. We were,
we were all set. I was hanging
out. I'm gonna tell right now.
We were hanging out right.
Me and this other dude,
and all of a sudden Nia shows up, right?
And I can see, I can see the vibe.
I see the look on her face. I know she
wants it now. I don't know. He just,
you know, shut up. You
look great. You came up,
he had a nice big smile and
you're being flirtatious.
And I immediately liked you,
right? So you went to the bathroom,
you're with a friend.
I'm with a friend.
Every guy knows what
you're supposed to do.
Take that fucking battle
ax out of the picture.
Okay. Take one for the team. I can't
remember. Who the fuck are you with.
So if it's one of your friends, I
apologize. Um, whatever. Alright,
a a war memorial. Um,
so what is this fucking,
he goes the opposite route. I said, look,
you went to Beth and I said, listen,
I'm really doing well with this girl.
All right, so a duty, I hate to like,
he was like a chick. No, I had to be like,
so if I'm not paying attention to you,
don't get upset. This is how like female,
this dude was, right. So I fucking,
he is what? He ends up doing.
Okay. The fucking guy ends up,
it's worth going to leave,
you know, I'm thinking, okay,
he's going to try to peel off with,
uh, your girl who's not a battle ax.
And he just, he invites another
dude over and goes, hey,
you guys all want to get something to eat,
remember and member.
And he invited us over. Now we're
sitting there. It's me. You,
you're not so battleaxe friends and three
other fucking cops are sitting there
and I'm trying to hit on you. Yeah. And he
keeps jumping in. Then he goes, Hey Nia,
where do you live? Oh, I live up
that way. You want to split a cab?
Right. Remember that? And
I had to be like, no, no,
no, you didn't. It was over at that point.
I made the move. Remember that? I said,
are you at least I bucked before
he fucking said that shit.
He was doing everything.
I remember I didn't have any cash and
I pulled out my credit card. I said,
you guys just give me the cash or just
put it on my credit card. And he goes, oh,
he's just trying to get the miles.
Remember that anything could Duke
to make me look like a shithead
for the whole thing. I thought you were
like Bam, I'm paying for the whole meal.
No,
no,
no, no. They gave me money cause I
didn't have any cash. You paid for mine.
This is how I got you.
What you were sitting there and I said,
look how we at least going to be able to
split a cab because I wanted to go over
and have a drink with you. Right. And I
was like at least be able to split a cab.
And then you like, why? Why
do you want to split a cab?
Just putting up the roadblock. And
that's when I went all in. I said,
cause I want to kiss you Bam.
Right? Yeah. And then that was it.
I didn't fucking talk to you after that.
Yeah,
you sat there with that little stunned
look on your face. Then what happened?
And we walked outside. Damn Damn Dad.
Then we walked out. That was the shit.
That was one of the greatest I used to
the fucking guys like that used to always
get me,
I fucking nailed that stuck the
landing like a male Mary Lou Retton
and you know what the best part
was. Then I stood up, we all, and I,
at that point I was like, fuck
it. I said what I wanted to do,
all this shit is in,
I don't need to talk to her anymore.
And I sort of peeled off,
right?
And then everybody got up to leave
and then you kind of touched me on the
shoulder, said, don't worry. She
goes, you say like, don't worry,
we're going to split a cab up
time. And then I'm like, oh,
this is going to be great because now I'm
in and now I'm going to get you get to
watch that little fucking cock block,
get his balls knocked on the, on the,
on the fucking sidewalk. And that's
what happened. He came out right?
Clapped his hands. Remember that
came out just like you, just like,
so you guys ready to go? Yeah.
And you were like, ah, yeah,
actually we're taking a cab. And he
was, and he was so in cock block mode,
he's still didn't have said, no,
no, we live right near [inaudible].
And you were like, listen, we're
taking a cab and we're going uptown.
You leaned over and you said it,
and then that's when he realized that
everyone realized he was a cock block and
Douche. And then what did he do? He
goes, oh good. Yeah. I mean, yeah,
he just fucking peeled off.
Yeah. Huh. Then what happened?
We can't talk about that.
My other fucking classic line, we're
fucking real. June was a masterpiece,
fucking masterpiece. Then we got
in the cab and you said, I thought,
I thought you were going to kiss me,
and we fucking drive it like a maniac.
And I go,
I can't the cabs jumping around too much.
I go a kiss you at the first red light,
right.
Rag it out and we're trying
to make this whole like,
I was fucking seducing
you and it worked right?
Then we hit the fucking red
light. I put one on you, Bam.
Right.
Couldn't feel your fucking feet.
I'm gonna make this story last nine hours
long. And then you know what happened?
Then I sat back and I was playing
mister fucking cool again,
like a fucking Walt Frazier in 1972 oh
the callback to the next from an hour
ago, right? Then what happened?
We stopped again and I'm sitting there
looking out the window and you go,
it's another red light right now.
And then,
and then we heard that cheesy saxophone
from every fucking sexy movie in the 80s
right? And then you were going,
I'm not going home with you.
I'm not going home with you. Now,
whenever they say that, guys,
you know they're not going home with you.
You know that shit.
So what you have to do is you have to
constantly make them feel like it's safe
and they're in control.
So before,
actually before you said you weren't
going home with me, I felt you vibe.
I knew the deal. So I just said, listen,
I know we're not going home together,
but I'm really am a good time with you.
I'd like to have another drink with you.
All right. I know a nice
bar. Ba, Ba, ba Ba and Bam,
right?
You didn't go home with me.
We had like fucking eight more drinks
and made out for like the next five hours
and that fucking hell's kitchen
bar had a great time. There you go.
So there's a little story people,
there's your little backstory hour in
one fucking minutes. There you go. Oh,
you know I've got, damn it. I
didn't get to this. You want it.
You want to hear something
that's going to make your uh,
your fucking privates crawl.
Sorry, I was disgusting.
I'm out of funny shit and that's
it. I'm, I'm overtime right now.
Listen to this guy. You know I was talking
about that, that cut down there at the,
at the diner that one day. Remember
that guy? Go back to Jersey.
You fucking faggot.
Whatever the hell he said.
So people,
people were talking about, people would,
talking about like all the, uh, you know,
all the assholes and the confrontations
and some people had the confrontations,
some people won the fights,
some people lost the fight,
some people won and got sued.
I let people walked away and had the
fucking anger like I did. So he goes,
a podcast, the bullies point of
view. This is from the bully.
Listen to this. This is
really interesting, Bill.
I just listened to your last two podcasts
and listen to the stories of these
guys that went. They want to beat
people when they're bullied. Well,
I think I'm the bully.
I've got a hundred stories,
but I'll give you two short ones,
right?
Fat People Bother me.
These guys, awesome.
Fair people bothering me.
Smelly people do to combine the two and
give me lots of alcohol and I go off.
So I'm down the,
uh,
down the hatch and Manhattan and fat
smelly and Fet smelly guys come in.
I can't help but tell them that they are
an embarrassment to the white American
race. This is where he becomes
like this area in psychopath.
I guess this isn't funny anymore.
And he goes,
and I'm tired of picking up their slack
if he's just saying that to be funny.
That's fucking hilarious.
For one white person to say
that to another white person.
You're an embarrassment to the white race
and I'm tired of picking up the slap.
Take a fucking walk. At least
he goes, they don't say a word.
So I slapped one right across
the face. He goes, why?
I'm not sure. What's that movie you
love there with, with Christian Bale?
American psych. Yeah. I think this is the
guy I'd love to see his business card.
He goes out, there's six of them.
I have four or five guys with me.
But they wouldn't have known that.
They wouldn't have known that.
And they just walked out.
They just walked away out the door
probably to grab some fried food.
Uh, but the point is they
didn't do anything. Did I
feel bad about it? Not really.
A, it's a pretty funny story
to tell when I'm drunk.
Oh, these stories are hilarious.
I don't even know if the true,
but these are fucking making me laugh.
A written element story too.
So I'm at a bar with a couple of
guys and there's a midget in, uh,
for some reason I don't
notice the little man,
but my friends do in the
midget jokes commence.
And one of the little men's friends
says something to my friend.
I told him to shut the fuck up
and poured my corona on him. Uh,
he didn't know what to do. About 10
minutes later, I ordered a shot and saw,
saw him near the bar and toss that
in him too. He did nothing. Why?
Because 98% of the time, people, uh,
people don't know how to react and clam
up. It's not just your listeners, a you,
it's mostly everyone.
So don't feel bad about freezing up
and missing your opportunity. Um,
and you're right that we don't
always get what we deserve.
I've been kicked out of more
bars than I can remember.
I've had sex with more women than I can
remember and showed all of my friends
pictures of them.
Where did it get me
to a six figure salary?
Wait a minute. You just want it to
be fake. You want it to be fake.
Nia. Have you ever seen an
asshole who takes what he wants?
Not Banging the hottest
fucking women out there ever.
Thank you. All right, let's continue.
One more thing just so this will
make you feel great. All these, uh,
all these guys in your podcast,
keep talking about picking up girls or
being scared to talk to them or being
rejected, rejected, rejected.
Listen, kids, I love this.
He's talking down to them.
Most of you are in college or
your senior years of high school.
Fucking go out there and crush some pussy.
Have trouble talking to girls. Here's
what you do. Go to your classes.
Come back to your dorm room and take a
nap or play Madden or do whatever till
around 1:00 AM go get a fake id or chalk
your id and move on to the bar about
one hour before they close. Scope out the
action in search for blood. Be a shark.
Look for the over inebriated,
the overweight, the low
self esteem. Make it happen.
He's screaming now, make it happen. He's
given a little halftime speech here. Uh,
be blunt.
Ask a girl if you can grab a little
stick a hand down a chick's pants when
you're on a dance floor, be
aggressive. All that shit works in the,
I'm not gonna lie to you putting
your hand down. Some girl's hands on,
but you just don't fucking
do what you just saw.
You start doing other areas
that are gateways to that area.
Lies, lies, lies. Yap. What if he
turns you on? What if you worked out?
What if he was a dick and he was shredded
and he just knew it was going to be
some great fucking stress relieving cock?
Nia,
uh, uh, you know what
you're doing right now.
Right now you'd be in talk show audience.
Nia, let me tell you about that.
Anybody puts their hand on my ass.
They get an ass kicked.
You're full of shit in here. All right.
Whenever you're sick, I'll let you go.
Um, oh and never play up the nice
guy thing. Uh, you go in there,
look like you've done this a hundred
times. Scared of performing. Don't worry,
they won't remember it anyways
and chances are they've had worse.
All right, so this guy's cocky.
You know, I love about him.
He's cocky for good reasons and
also cocky for no reasons. I mean,
I know well, he's a, he slaps fat people.
He makes fun of Friends of midgets.
Any fucks?
A girls who are too drunk to say no,
and now he makes six figures.
Come on. You know we was, she was trying
to be funny, but you know he did a song.
You know? Now you've got the
attitude. You don't care if she comes,
stays laser praise. You ever see
them? I'm that guy. [inaudible]
you know what's funny?
You know what's funny about you?
You already have that look on your face
when you meet a guy who doesn't give a
fuck the same way I didn't.
You got that look on your face.
That fucking look that.
Let me know that someday you are going
to be in my bedroom, which you are.
I just didn't count on me falling for you.
That's where I fucked up.
That's where you turn the tables on me.
Huh? Cutie Pie. All right, that's it.
That's it for the podcast.
You're fucking twats. You guys,
I got to end on the left and sometimes
we don't have a joke. You go dirty.
I'm teaching these people
how to be a comedian. If I
was on, if they could see me,
I just would have made a funny face.
That's all my act is.
I curse words and silly faces. All
right, that's a podcast for this week.
I Apologize, um, to you mother
fuckers for uh, you know,
taking so God damn long, but
uh, I hope you enjoy it. And
uh, my next Gig is Tempe,
the Improv in Tempe, Arizona. I appreciate
it. Uh, anybody who can come out,
please come out to the show cause it's
getting close to my special and tickets
will be going on sale for my special,
I will have information next Monday.
Repeat actually checking on my website
[inaudible] dot com I might have a,
uh,
a special announcement this week and if
you want to be in on tickets as soon as
you can,
uh,
sign up for my mailing list at [inaudible]
dot com just sign up under the city
that, uh, the most,
the closest major city. And, um,
I'll send out an email right
before I do the announcement.
That'll be your little plus for getting
on my mailing list. Look at that knee.
A little business skill there. You
like that? Look at me. All right,
let's go have some pork. Chet. What
the fuck are we eating for dinner?
Wow. You don't feel like cooking
anymore. I took you to Sweden in August.
You drove in a corvette and fucking
October, you're not going to cook.
So what the fuck am I supposed to eat?
You're not sick even laughing your
ass off. You're coming out of it.
You're too silly to be sick,
Huh?
Pasta. That's what I ate when I was
single and I was fucking struggling.
Really?
Can I eat it on like of the fucking
back of a chair the way I used to ice.
Put the plate right where you sit. I
already told his fucking story. All right.
Thank you everybody. Have a wonderful
week. I'll talk to you next month.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].